so there's a there's a bunch of theories
about how the election will go down
and a lot of a lot of people think that
it's going to end up in the courts with
lawsuits about various elections
and that will ultimately lead to the
supreme court and will have to go fast
because there's a deadline so at least
according to one of the sources i was
reading on potentials they say the
deadline i think is like december 14th
i'm not entirely sure but that's when
the electoral vote uh the other the
electoral college votes have to be
tallied okay
and that's when they decide you know the
supreme court will have to intervene or
you know or not so i imagine they will
if we do not have a full court and it
could potentially go 4-4
then this country is going to face the
worst crisis it's faced in you know
100-plus years yeah
and even if everything goes well it
could be a unanimous court and it would
still be a crisis right i think one of
the important things
to keep in mind for the election is it
really is 50 different simultaneous
elections that go on simultaneously
under their own different set of rules
right we're talking about pennsylvania
throwing out
uh signature signature verification so
you have all of these different kind of
minute factors of the law
that are all legal challenges that could
all get fast tracked and so the just the
number of cases that could spin out the
amount of energy that would have to go
into this
is enormous what if what if we come out
of election day we're three or four days
post
and we don't know because of mailing
irregularities or whatever it is
we don't know who won florida we don't
know who won pennsylvania and i don't
know we don't know who won wisconsin
could that be so when we've talked about
civil war and and i gotta preface this
by saying i know there's a lot of people
who are like they roll their eyes when
it's brought up
but i'm not the one who for i i didn't
come up with this idea i was i was
reading a national security article from
i think the atlantic
talking about the violence in the
streets the escalation of tensions
following donald trump's victory
and the potential for civil war and this
was several years ago
they said that it looked like there was
like a 35 percent chance we would go
down that route
a lot of people i talked to said there's
no dividing line like this the american
civil war was the north and the south we
knew where people were
and i said but that's not a traditional
civil war like we've seen with other
countries around the world
right where there's pockets that are in
alignment and then they like move around
and then slowly try and take over
one city or where they just wage a war
on the capital until they win control of
the centralized you know government
right i wonder if that scenario you just
brought up
would be that state dividing line
because we have a lot of swing states
that have
uh i shouldn't say a lot but there's a
couple where they have a democratic
governor but a republican legislature
right
so i think wisconsin pennsylvania and uh
no no not michigan
it's michigan and wisconsin i think yeah
so i wonder what happens if
there's these democratic governors who
will say something like
imagine this i keep seeing the left say
many many progressives
that we need to make sure we have
maximum voter turnout for joe biden
the only problem is they all live in
blue states they all live in deep blue
states
right and hyper con like heavily
concentrated in
uh cities so a lot of people did move
because
of of covid but i don't think they moved
that far yeah they probably went to
their parents house in the suburbs or
something like that
right if they all come out and vote so
what new york which was already going to
give its electoral votes
has a higher you know popular vote count
yeah so what
however what happens when joe biden
loses the electoral college but wins the
popular vote by 10 points
then you're going to see these democrat
governors in the swing states be like
well we did vote for you know trump in
our state but the popular part of the
country is more you know
more important because the swing is too
high right you'll end up with some
people saying
we know trump won the electoral college
but this is too big of a popular vote
swing we will not be ruled by a minority
right and then the republicans and trump
are going to say these are the rules
and this is what we all agreed to and
then all of a sudden you have
some kind of civil war but i think so
two thoughts come to me the first
is i think the response from the left
will be yeah well we agreed to these
rules hundreds of years ago when there
was still slavery right that's always
the push back on the electoral college
and there's there's a sideway that's
like okay like i get it like we have a
living breathing constitutional document
it's meant to change all that kind of
stuff but there's a lot of things you
have to go through to change things in
this country and i think
on the whole that's probably for the
best electoral college included
but getting back to your your civil war
model i also i read something
the other day that was really really
interesting that looked at it that
talked about it
less as a traditional civil war even in
the sense of two standing armies even if
it's not north south but like even look
at a place like libya right
that kind of devolves into a sort of
civil war and a lot more like the
troubles in ireland
right and so it could look a lot more
like you have kind of pockets of
sectarian violence where you have
it's not even one city against another
it's you got 60 percent of one city
maybe that's loyal to a cause and 40
percent the other way
and so you start having unfortunately
what it ends up looking like is a lot
like portland with more people dead
and live ammo i remember uh i i went to
um
northern ireland uh what what's the uh
what's what's the city
in uh in northern ireland do you know so
fast belfast yeah yes i was in belfast
and i went to the peace wall there you
went to did you go to the peace wall i
did yeah right so this is really
important for everyone that's listening
on one side of the peace wall there was
like pro-israel stuff
on the other side there was
pro-palestine and i was confused by this
and i asked one of the locals what does
this have to do
with with ireland and he said nothing
yeah
it was literally tribalism if one side
said one thing the other side said the
opposite
we are seeing that it's uh matt tybee
called it uh
there's something akin to this that
maybe coined the hydroxychloroquine
effect yes
right you read that article yes so right
he's a liberal guy
yeah and he wrote basically that you
know look trump sees
these studies that were being performed
in many different modernized nations
he then goes up on the podium and starts
you know saying oh this is really really
great i saw this thing we should try it
out yeah the media then ran as fast they
could to write stories
claiming it was bad and not to do it
right and he said you're in a pandemic
and you're discounting a potential
treatment that other countries that
that's ridiculous
and right off the bat too two threads
i'll tell you i actually have about
about the hydroxychloroquine effect and
it's right i mean it was there was
nothing about it that was science and
what ended up happening was all they had
to do was cherry-pick doctors who have
a doctor before their name throw them on
cnn and then they run the coverage of
trump and like
let's be honest too trump is not a
medical expert and so he goes
when he goes up there and talks about it
it's typical trump's speech trying to
explain something very complicated
and then all of these doctors who
probably are sound and look a lot more
articulate on the ways of medicine
get up there and say no he's he's crazy
but they're cherry-picking they're just
finding guys who believe a certain thing
that doesn't necessarily fit any of the
evidence and there was uh
and and there were some really bad
doctors who came out in
an agreement with trump that made him
look really bad very good point however
you also had doctor
i think was harvey rich md phd from yale
saying yeah the most important thing
whenever we talk about this too because
youtube likes to strike down anybody who
brings it up is that
it's a it's not a cure but uh this phd
md from yale was saying
it does help and we need to start you
know looking into what we can do to help
people but it's not a cure for sure
so anyway i bring that up in in context
of northern ireland because
there was like i think somebody somebody
in northern ireland claimed they were a
lost tribe of israel
and they're like literally irish people
yeah for interesting this is what i was
being told by some of the locals
that you'll look on one side and it's
the revolution fist it's pro communist
it's pro left the other side was
pro right wing pro empire pro
imperialism yeah and it was literally
just your side bad
our side good interesting and i think
that's where we are
yeah but i don't i here's what here's
what i actually i think when it comes to
the us
and and the kind of the conflict we've
seen from the left and the right
the right has become a big tent of
people who are rational and reasonable
and willing to have a conversation and
don't just believe that
whatever you know one person says it you
know that we must say the other thing
but if you look like when i look at
trump i say there's a lot of things i
can easily criticize there's a lot of
things i think that are good you know
hey it is what it is
the left just says literally everything
he does is bad right the peace
agreements oh they're actually bad they
undermine palestine how dare he
yeah it looks like we're headed in that
in that similar direction to what
divided
uh uh at least what i saw from you know
look it's not like i have a history
degree in northern ireland or anything
fair but and i think i think one of the
big things within that too is
you end up with a situation where it's
not just that one side has decided that
whatever the other side is doing is is
bad is you have one side who's in power
right donald trump and you have the
other side who's controlling the
narrative and the media right and so if
they're going to sit back and say
whatever the government of the united
states does is bad right and in a way
that can only be described as propaganda
then you're of course you're going to
inflame tensions of course you're going
to piss people off
and at the end of the day anyone who
agrees with trump is going to sit back
and say
why am i being lied to so what do you
think happens
when trump then selects his supreme
court nominee
the media is going to magically create
every every possible you name it they're
going to accuse this person of
murder they're going to be like they
they kidnapped a puppy and threw it
you know if a bridge it's going to be
insanity but this is why i think
trump has to pick amy coney barrett
if they choose a man it's going to be me
too it's going to be white
kavanaugh all over again times a
thousand yeah times a thousand thousand
and with a thousand times the energy
behind it to dig up anything that could
be
wrong or unsavory or whatever it is no
they're gonna make it up and that's the
thing
when all else fails you know that they
will so what can they make up so so
here's here's what i've got pulled up i
got wikipedia pulled up with amy coney
barrett
and uh there's a really important
context here they say amy coney barrett
is a united states circuit
uh united states circuit judge of the
united states court of appeals for the
seventh circuit
barrett is the first and only woman to
occupy an indiana seat
on the seventh uh seventh circuit court
of appeals described as an originalist
and textualist barrett's judicial
philosophy has been likened to that of
her late mentor and former boss
justice antonin scalia barrett's
scholarship focused on originalism
statutory interpretation and i can't
bring a cunning pronounce that star a
story decisis starry decisis let the
decision stand interesting
yeah so that like what does that mean
like you don't repeal or re reverse
other standings right
it's that it's at you you tend to side
with settled case law or previous court
decisions
so so the question i guess i would ask
if that's true do you think she wouldn't
overturn roe v wade
or would she it's interesting she was
she was asked about this
i don't know if it's a confirmation
hearing or what but she's been asked
throughout the years whether or not she
believes in roe v wade whether or not
it's settled law
um i think she probably doesn't over i i
think
you think she won't i don't think she
will reverse roe v wade to be honest
with you i
i get what tom cotton's saying and tom
cotton's an elected official so i think
it's a lot easier for him to say that it
needs to be overturned
i think it would be enormously difficult
i think you would probably need a couple
more conservative justices to actually
overturn your overview i
just i don't buy it right it's something
that the conservative movement has
fought for for a long time
um and done a really good job of
fighting for and i think it's it's
animated the conservative movement for a
long time i don't think it changes but
to answer your earlier question
i think i have a pretty good idea of
what's going to come out about coney oh
yeah i think i know
so she she's catholic she teaches at
notre dame and they're gonna paint her
and they did this the last time i think
she was confirmed they're gonna paint
her as a religious
zealot oh yeah they're gonna i think she
i it might have been her might have been
someone i'm confusing her with but
um she has membership in different
catholic organizations i think opus dye
maybe a couple of the others you'll
remember opus dei if you've seen the da
vinci code
uh that's not actually opus die they
just they use so she's not like hiding
secret paper oh exactly she's
exactly right she's not it would be cool
if it was the case but no i to the best
of my knowledge she doesn't have any any
interesting secrets doesn't drink the
blood from the skull of saint peter or
anything like that but
uh but she's a conservative catholic
woman
yeah but but also like deeply fundam
not not fundamentalist but fundamentally
as an in her
in her bearing and in her being
religious that's what it's going to be
it's going to be a culture war about
religion so i i can see it already
because dianne feinstein this is the
lady to whom she was saying the dogma
lives loudly this is dogma lives loudly
thank you
yeah okay i remember this is this is dog
i can
i can preview it through the kavanagh
thing yeah there there i'm not going to
go through her entire wiki
that points out several interesting
things but i will note that uh right
away they say she's
a wrangfully descent in favor of gun
ownership rights but also fourth
amendment interestingly the first thing
they bring up is
barrett wrote the opinion in a case
denying summary judgment and qualified
immunity to a police detective who
knowingly provided false and misleading
information in an affidavit
interesting the plaintiff reinsberger
was arrested for his own mother's murder
based upon the defendant's falsified
records
used to secure a warrant for the
plaintiff's arrest the court found
the defendant's lies and emissions were
material to probable probably cause a
clear violation
of the plaintiff's fourth amendment
rights to which the defendant is not
eligible for qualified immunity
so uh i legally is a little bit there
but does that
she's not she actually was against
qualified immunity for a cop is that
what it says
it's sort of so if i'm reading it right
it's that
you have a lot of courts who have a
pretty expansive interpretation of what
qualified immunity is and what it means
and so if i'm reading that correctly
again i don't have a lot of grace so i
don't want to mislead any of your
viewers but
my understanding is that she struck down
qualified immunity because of a direct
violation of
enunciated protection right right under
the constitution which
not all courts do right i think
unfortunately it's it's with
um can you can you can you give quick
contacts on a qualified immunity yeah so
qualified immunity is
for certain people in most cases it
comes off comes up around police
officers
is that because of the responsibilities
of their job or something that they do
they have a it's a higher burden of
proof to be able to hold them legally
accountable and so
if you get killed by a police officer it
is very very difficult for your family
to then go and sue
the government and sue the police bureau
so this is something a lot of left-wing
activists
have been adamant about they want police
to lose qualified immunity right so that
they get treated like regular people
essentially yes
right so i i guess that might be
favorable
for her it's not like it's going to
matter though she's a conservative
that's a good point yeah they'll hate
you anyway that that point i think is
good for the libertarians that's been a
big
that's like uh like reason i'm sure has
a podcast on
qualified immunity or whatever it is
right that's one of their big sticking
points
um i think i think there's probably
enough there on the rest of the wiki for
why comey barrett is not going to be
someone who's embraced
open arms right away rpg fans right away
the 2a gun ownership right stuff of
course
if she's an original list and text you a
list i mean but but she
it's interesting she's original and
textualist but she's not going to
reverse
you know previous rulings is that like
is that what
yeah i think is yes sorry decisions so
it's interesting i think the two are
somewhat intention right you've got
something
so sorry to decide this is yes you're
not overturning previous court decisions
i think there is a long legal tradition
among originalists to say that you don't
want to like
the whole the whole point of religionism
particularly as a political
manifestation is
we shouldn't be legislating from the
bench we shouldn't be making laws and
making rules and changing things
based on the judicial philosophy of
individual courts right that's kind of
the
the crux in the heart of it but what i
think a lot of what a lot of
originalists and textualists will do is
they'll say
that doesn't mean that we can't look at
cases that were wrongly decided
right right and go back and say this was
wrong and we need to change it rather
than we're looking at all the same packs
and figures and it comes out differently
so um yeah i think that's about where it
nets out
there is a section for possible supreme
court nomination
and they say barrett had been included
on president donald trump's list of
potential supreme court nominees since
2017
almost immediately after her court of
appeals confirmation that's wow
almost immediately after yeah in july
2017. yeah she's 40 47 i think
40 46 07. uh in july 2018 following the
retirement announcement of anthony
kennedy
she was reportedly one of three
finalists and the only woman to be
considered by trump as a possible
successor to kennedy
trump nominated judge brett kavanaugh
for the position reportedly
although the president liked barrett he
was concerned about her lack of
experience on the bench
at the time barrett had been on the
bench for less than a year after
kavanaugh's selection bear was expected
to stay
in the spotlight as a possible nominee
for a future supreme court vacancy
trump is reportedly saving ruth bader
ginsburg's seat for amy coney barrett
if ginsberg retires or dies during the
trump presidency
and there it is yeah that's what uh
everyone is expecting to happen and now
she's got the experience on the bench
yeah she's exactly she's got a little
more time on the bench also interesting
someone should fact check me on this but
i think this is accurate i think she
would also be
the first um the first individual on the
supreme court who doesn't have a law
degree from an ivy league school
really i think it's almost always yale
and harvard
she went to notre dame again i could be
wrong on this or it could be
undergraduate rather than graduate
but do they university of notre dame
yeah so i'm
i think i think she would be the first
one with a law degree
not from an ivy league school who would
be on the supreme court
wow man i don't know that that really
gets you any blue-collar voters i mean
yeah i think that's
that's probably like how many angels can
dance on the head of the pin in terms of
the things that yeah yeah
it's a little too in the weeds but uh
nerdy people like me and dc i think
probably like that stuff
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time
you